bienvenue à toutes
dans ce nouveau trois théories dédié à
la fin de la série de loki sa saison 2
ou encore notamment quand le conquérant
je ne vais pas vous mentir le sujet est
un peu complexe
tout simplement car c'est marvel qui
établit les règles que ce soit
concernant le multivers le temps le tva
et j'en passe et bien évidemment il ils
font exprès de nous en dire le moins
possible et du coup nous sommes
totalement dans le flou alors c'est
l'axé drôle du coup puisque chacun a sa
propre vision et ce n'est pas forcément
une vision un correct puisque nous
n'avons pas de vraie réponse donc tout
est plausible en quelque sorte
bref tout ça pour vous dire que je vais
vous partager trois théories qui
traduisent totalement ma vision
personnelle et mes idées et caetera et
je vous avoue que ma perception des
choses a pas mal évolué en une semaine
accompagné de mon variant heroes f il
est temps de rentrer en profondeur dans
l'avenir du mc eu et plus
particulièrement de la série de lots
qu'ils allaient que le trois théories
commence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous avons tout d'abord parlé d'une
théorie qui est plutôt connue et qui
génère beaucoup de débats mais
évidemment je vais vous proposer ma
vision personnelle de la chose et mes
idées ce n'est un secret pour personne
bien que joe nathan mayer s'est
introduit le concept de ganges le
conquérant d'une morte us des variants
de nathaniel et serah diallo qui a
l'atout de base
la seule information que nous avions
concernant ce dernier était que kan veut
conquérant serait présent dans ant man 3
ce qui signifie du coup que entre man et
gangs ont un lien en commun encore
inconnue à ce jour et nous le verrons
bien évidemment dans ce prochain film
qu'est entre man 3 sauf que il faut
penser logique et une cohérence entre
man s'il ya bien une chose qui le
caractérise dans le mc eu c'est le chant
quantique
ce n'est pas méchant ce que je vais dire
mais la fonction est l'utilité
principale dante man et ses alliés c'est
le chant quantique
donc ce qui va lier scotland et kong
c'est le chant quantique évidemment et
pour entrer dans le vif du sujet
j'aimerais que vous vous rappeliez deux
ans man 2 en parcourant le champ
quantique à la recherche de djanet la
première guêpe et épouse de hank pym
nous pouvons apercevoir au loin une
mystérieuse ville cachait dans le champ
quantique abrité par un dôme
cette ville pourrait à très fortes
chances être chrono police la ville et
la base appartenant à quang le
conquérant un endroit où il est maître
de tout et où il gère ces royaumes ses
conquêtes une ville composée également
de gratte-ciel et qui est abritée par un
dôme
donc cela fait sens surtout que les
films batman nous propose une évolution
de la maîtrise du chant quantique dans
le premier film scott a réussi à y aller
et revenir dans le 2 ils ont un peu plus
exploré la chose et exploiter l'énergie
quantique dans le iii ils vont forcément
aller encore plus loin
néanmoins nous sommes dans le mc eu et
ça il ne faut jamais l'oublier
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que les
concepts sont simplifiées remaniée et
surtout lié ans
les films sont liés ensemble l'exemple
le plus récent est parfait pour le
démontrer le som face dans look et à une
représentation du maure tus invariants
de nathaniel richarde mais qui est aussi
celui qui demeure une fusion de deux
personnages pour l'adaptation dans le mc
eu et c'est là où j'aimerais aller et si
cette ville du chant quantique qui est à
très fortes chances chrono police serait
aussi le tva tout d'abord cela
permettrait de tout relier ensemble et
de créer la continuité entre les films
et les séries de m6 mais surtout s'il ya
bien un mystère concernant la série law
qui sait le tva
nous ne savons absolument rien sur ce
lieu où ils se trouvent s'il est
véritablement hors du temps et de
l'espace
et c'est un mystère que marvel souhaite
nous cacher ils ne veulent donner aucune
réponse et nous devrons attendre les
prochaines productions pour en savoir
plus mais comme vous vous en doutez j'ai
ma théorie est donc une explication à
vous proposer
le tva qui nous est proposé à la fin de
la série law qui correspond parfaitement
à l'idée que nous pourrions nous faire
d'un chrono police la statue imposante
de quang situé dans une grande ville où
tout le monde lui obéit et où il peut
faire la guerre à d'autres univers
correspond parfaitement à la description
de chronos police la base de kango le
conquérant où il est maître de tout et
où il gère ces royaumes
sans oublier la seule et unique
information qui nous est partagé par
mobius concernant le tva c'est que le
temps passe différemment mais qu'est ce
qu'il veut dire exactement par là
nous savons que dans le chant quantique
le temps passe différemment également
janet van dyne est restée environ 30 ans
là bas mais pour elle cela n'a duré que
trente heures mais surtout comme
démontré dans endgame le champ quantique
est un lieu clé permettant de se relier
à toutes les réalités et tous les
moments du temps puisque grâce à la
technologie de tony et les particules de
hank pym les avengers ont pu voyager
dans le temps et accéder aux époques
qu'il souhaitait et c'est quelque chose
qui séduit forcément kangs lui qui est
liée au temps et aux réalités qu'ils
cherchent à conquérir le champ quantique
lui propose une dimension lui permettant
d'accéder à n'importe quel moment du
temps et donc les réalités de manière
très simple et justement par rapport à
ça il faut rester cohérent et logique
par rapport à l'univers du mc eu celui
qui demeure nous a expliqué que
nathaniel richarde était un scientifique
qui a fait la découverte que les univers
étaient empilés et que du coup ils
pouvaient entrer en contact avec ces
variants etc
et il ne faut pas oublier que nathaniel
vient du 31ème siècle
c'est très important ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que dans les comics ce
dernier s'est inspiré des travaux du dr
doom pour approfondir le voyage dans le
temps et l'expérimenté et c'est là que
c'est intéressant car par rapport au mc
une nous pouvons supposer que nathaniel
s'est inspiré des travaux de tony stark
et de hank pym pour justement
appréhender le champ quantique lui
permettant de voyager dans le temps
d'expérimenter les réalités et
rencontrer son lui d'autres époques
le truc c'est que nathaniel n'est pas le
premier à avoir expérimenté le voyage
dans le temps puisque tony est un crime
l'ont déjà fait un millénaire avant lui
il a donc dû forcément s'inspirer de
leurs travaux pour approfondir ses
connaissances et les travaux de tony et
anpihm sont liés aux champs quantique la
dimension qui leur a permis d'effectuer
le voyage dans tandem games et
accessoirement créer une nouvelle
réalité par rapport à loki qui s'est
échappé avec le tesseract et tout ça
nathaniel a pu l'expérimenter le
comprendre et l'approfondir au point de
coloniser le champ quantique et crée le
tva enfin il ne faut pas oublier que
kong n'est pas un magicien c'est un
scientifique
donc tout ce qui touche le tva son
existence sa composition et cetera eh
bien il n'y a rien de magique tout et
scientifique et technologique
c'est pourquoi je pense que le tva
serait situé dans le champ quantique
ma vision a changé par rapport à la
dernière vidéo
nous sommes face à un véritable flou les
règles du multivers ne sont pas encore
véritablement établie par marvel et plus
particulièrement par kevin fait guy et
son équipe et on le ressent bien la fin
de l'eau qui tease énormément sur
l'avenir du mc eu mais c'est compliqué
de déterminer la vérité sur tout ça
étant donné que le mc lui se base sur
les comics pour réécrire l'histoire je
vous propose de faire un petit tour là
bas pour essayer de déceler certaines
réponses dans les comics à la fin des
temps celui qui demeure donne naissance
à trois êtres trois êtres qui devront
reprendre le flambeau et gérer tout ce
qu'a établi celui qui demeure et c'est
déjà quelque chose que l'on retrouve
dans l'épisode 6 de loki celui qui
demeure propose à sylvie et look et de
reprendre ce qu'il fait de continuer son
oeuvre
mais là où c'est intéressant c'est que
dans les comics la fin des temps traduit
de futurs possibles car en fait ces
trois êtres né de la main de celui qui
demeure deviendront soit les time
twisters soit les time keepers pour être
simple et efficace l'univers fonctionne
en cycle
c'est à dire qu'à la fin des temps tout
se meurt et le prochain univers se met
en place et le cycle continue c'est la
thématique de la boucle dont je vous
avais déjà parlé dans la vidéo
précédente
les trois êtres ont été créés pour
justement s'occuper du prochain univers
sauf qu'il était défaillant car au lieu
de s'occuper du futur ils sont retournés
dans le passé au tout début de l'univers
et ont mis le bazar
celui qui demeure a dû intervenir et les
supprimer sauf que pour les supprimer
il a dû retourner au moment de leur
création c'est ce qu'il a fait et en
corrigeant la défaillance
il a donné naissance au thème keepers
qui eux ont bien fait leur travail
sauf que cette action a divisé l'univers
en deux une réalité où les thèmes
twisters continue d'exister et une houle
et m keepers existe car oui on avance
constamment dans le temps donc modifier
le passé ne modifie pas le présent cela
crée simplement
une autre branche c'est d'ailleurs la
même explication le même fonctionnement
dans avengers and games pour revenir à
la série law qui est son futur nous
retrouvons énormément de similitudes et
de symboles par rapport à ça notamment
la thématique du yin et du yang ou
encore de l'ordre et du chaos dont je
vous avais déjà parlé mais le plus
intéressant et qu'il ya clairement un
écho de l'histoire des comics gare la
fin de nos qui nous propose également
deux futurs possibles un futur où l'eau
qui est sylvie reprennent le flambeau de
ce qu'a établi celui qui demeure ce qui
signifie donc ils deviendraient les time
keepers et un futur où il tue celui qui
demeure et du coup bas bonne chance à
tous que l'on pourrait associer au times
twisters mais là où c'est encore plus
sexy c'est que dans ces deux réalités
des comics il ya une réalité ou
nathaniel richard's devient immortel et
dans l'autre où ils refusent de le
devenir et devient donc kangs le
conquérant et cela peut clairement donné
de belles choses par rapport à la fin de
l'eau qui pour l'avenir dans le mc eu je
ne vais pas vous mentir l'idée que kong
le conquérant censé devenir l'ennemi
ultime de la phase 4 de marvel soit
juste un variant parmi tant d'autres qui
débarque juste comme ça bah je trouve
pas ça très dingue
l'idée que le choix de sylvie et donc tu
es celui qui demeure est influencer
l'avenir de l'univers voir les scinder
en deux créant une réalité au gang est
né et l'autre ou immo russe eni est
beaucoup plus séduisant et cela
expliquerait du coup pourquoi l'eau qui
se retrouvent dans un tva alternatif
avec comme symbole loki traduisant le
time keeper celui qu'ils considéraient
poursuivre l'oeuvre de celui qui demeure
et sylvie une time twister qui souhaite
redonner l'éclat du libre arbitre
l'ordre contre le chaos
bien évidemment cela remet en cause
l'idée qu'il existe qu'un seul tva
hélas aucune réponse ne nous est donnée
comme je disais dans la théorie
précédente mais essayez de considérer
cette approche les symboles sont
clairement là
[Musique]
pour finir j'aimerais que nous parlions
du retour de celui qui demeure la fin de
look et à taquiner de représentation du
morte us to correspond parfaitement
même s'il a été mixé avec l'entité de
celui qui demeure des comics à tout ce
qui symbolise immo russe dans ces fameux
comics on le retrouve plus ou moins dans
l'eau qui je pense notamment à la
fameuse mission qu'il s'est auto attitré
celle de conserver sa maîtrise du temps
et donc du flux sacré temporel afin que
ses autres variantes ne viennent pas
tout détruire
et c'est justement un rôle qu'il a dans
les comics et que nous pouvons liés à la
théorie précédente dans les comics les
thèmes qui peuvent lui donne en quelque
sorte le rôle de protecteur du temps il
doit s'assurer que le cours de
l'histoire mène à la fin des temps à la
création des townshippers pour le
prochaine univers est lui-même
s'autoprotègent en guidant son nathaniel
du passé a bel et bien devenir immortel
et tout ça c'est hyper intéressant et
important car cela permet de mieux
appréhender les concepts de l'eau qui
est l'avenir du mcc que nous sommes sur
une sorte de boucle un cycle par rapport
aux explications de celui qui demeure le
multivers aurait en fait toujours existé
sauf que nathaniel a fait la découverte
de l'existence des univers compiler et
le problème c'est que ces variants ont
voulu prendre le dessus sur les autres
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que comme
toujours l'homme a tout saccagé
les variants de nathaniel ont eu accès à
quelque chose qui les dépasse totalement
et ont voulu l'exploiter sauf que la
solution à ce problème a été de tout
régulé d'instaurer la dictature
empêchant la création de nouvelles
réalités de nouvelles branches sauf qu'à
la fin des temps
le multivers se relance et il faut le
réguler de nouveau pour pas que les
variants fasse une nouvelle guerre sauf
que sylvie a tué celui qui demeure mais
c'est là que nous pouvons faire la
liaison avec les comics car à la fin des
temps l'existence dit morte us prend fin
sauf que pour éviter que ces autres
variant détruisent tout il a guidé son
lui dû passer sur le chemin le feu
en devenir immortel et c'est quelque
chose que nous semblons retrouver à la
fin de l'eau qui nous ne savons pas au
sens varavan arènes slayer mais nous
savons que sa destination a été défini
par celui qui demeure qui lui a donné
accès à certains fichiers certaines
données
ramona aurait été envoyé par celui qui
demeure retrouver son lui du passé pour
le guider afin qu'il devienne le nouveau
celui qui demeure qu'il emprunte le même
chemin que celui du futur
une mécanique intéressante car on se
doute bien que celui qui demeure ne
laisserait pas tout ce qu'il a bâti être
détruits comme ça sur un coup de tête de
sylvie obnubilé par la vengeance est
d'ailleurs on le rappelle encore une
fois mais ramona est morte us ont une
célèbre histoire d'amour dans les comics
donc cela fait clairement sens et comme
je vous disais dans la précédente vidéo
du chaos naît l'ordre et de l'ordre
n'aient le chaos
immo russe ou plus exactement celui qui
demeure est le gagnant de la guerre
multi vercel mais justement il sera le
gagnant car il serait guidé par son lui
du futur lui permettant donc d'accéder à
la victoire
dans tous les cas cela nous permettra de
connaître et vivre le passé du
personnage et donc de mieux appréhender
gang et ces variants d'ailleurs
n'oublions pas que parmi tous les
variants les deux principaux qui
s'opposent son team lotus et quang
l'ordre contre le chaos une opposition
est à la fois une complémentarité tout
comme l'eau qui est sylvie imaginez si
sylvie choisissez de suivre kang alors
que l'eau qu'ils suivraient team hortus
bon ok j'avoue lâche par un petit peu
loin mais attendez vous en tout cas à
revoir celui qui demeure
merci d'être arrivée jusque ici j'espère
sincèrement que la vidéo vous aura plu
c'est un petit peu l'introduction du
post lucky on va dire cette vidéo la
saison une est maintenant passé le
mystère est dévoilée et c'est à nous
maintenant nous débrouiller de trouver
les réponses
ce qui nous manque et c'est franchement
ça me manquait de ouf
n'hésitez pas à me faire part de vos
idées de vos théories en commentaires de
vos perceptions
c'est toujours un plaisir de vous lire
comme pour la vidéo de l'épisode 6 où
vous avez été très nombreux à réagir
c'était vraiment hyper intéressant on se
retrouve très très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos concernant bah du coup
ce fameux multivers 1 je pense qu'il va
falloir que nous répondions à la
question du coût de spider man 3 noël ou
encore dr strange de multivers of
madness
donc voilà le rendez vous est donné en
attendant foncez voir la vidéo de mon
variant heroes f
évidemment vous propose aujourd'hui une
double vidéo il est apparu dans la
mienne et du coupage apparaît dans la
sienne c'est toujours un véritable
plaisir de vous proposer ce genre de
projet et puis abonnez vous à nos
chaînes n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleu du cou et à nous suivre sur
les réseaux comme twitter ou instagram
par exemple et que le 'lion' art soit
avec vous écoutez cet argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]